a small group of protesters try to march
to thailand's health ministry
but the police are determined not to let
them through
they're protesting both the scarcity of
vaccination shots
and the vaccines the government is
giving them
i'm worried about the vaccine that the
government has ordered for us
many people including myself don't want
sinovac vaccine
but the government keeps ordering more
reassuring words from a senior health
official have little impact
a leaked memo shows that the government
is keen to defend
synovac's effectiveness despite doctors
concerns
with health officials unwilling to push
other vaccines
for fear of denting public confidence
to illustrate their concerns the
protesters pour paint on bound model
corpses
and attempt to cremate them security
guards quickly step in
synovac was the first vaccine to be
released in thailand and was quickly
distributed to frontline medical workers
most of whom have now had two doses but
as the new covert delta variant spread
some found they weren't protected here
there were five medical
staff infected with covid19 and two were
admitted to the icu
others are concerned by a lack of
information about synovac's results
although test groups show the vaccine
works wider studies have been harder to
find
it's the problem about the transparency
of the report
when it is studied in larger group of
participants it seems like that that
information
is not getting out of
the investigator's hand that could be a
real problem for thailand
domestic production has stalled and
delivers of the more effective
mrna vaccines won't arrive till the
autumn
thailand had a real problem finding
enough supplier vaccine to meet demand
at the current rates the whole country
won't be fully vaccinated
until the middle of next year at a local
temple
people have been queueing overnight just
to get a covered test
increasingly difficult in thailand which
now has record daily infection rates
despite early successes in the fight
against covert 19
thailand's response is now looking
poorly planned and ill-prepared
now many are questioning their faith in
the government's ability
to respond tony chang al jazeera bangkok